I'm five in this picture
and this is what I looked like when I started hating my body
and thinking that I was too fat and
like wanting to lose weight and like
just not being comfortable myself
this is this is what I look like
this is what I look like
when the adults around me started telling me that I needed to lose weight
like of course yes
I was a chubby kid
but oh my god
looking back at these picture makes me genuinely want
I don't want my video to get taken down
but it makes me very angry
because this little girl should have just been worried about ballet
been worried about being a child
she shouldn't have been so worried about her
but I remember this photo shoot and feeling bad
because the way this dress fit me compared to all the other little girl
I felt bad about myself and my body
like I'm a child I'm a child
my heart genuinely breaks for this little girl
because she deserved so much better than what she got
like she's a kid
she's a child
I can't imagine now
at my grown age
being an adult
looking at a child like this and commenting on her weight
I genuinely do not understand how you can see this little girl
and the first thing you think is
oh she's fat
I need to tell her she's fat and make her lose weight
everything that I do now as an adult
I do because this little girl didn't have an adult like me in her life
she did not have one person in her life
at this age I was 5
6 maybe you're allowed to just exist in your body
nobody said that
and that's why I do not care how much hate I get
how many videos are made about me
how much shit is
like thrown at
I will not stop talking about Celebration
body positivity
because this little girl needed someone like me in her life
and now as an adult
that is all I wanna do